on the right he said the desktop of John
Austin a program manager based in the US
on the left you see the desktop of Peter
Krebbs a developer working in Europe
they're going to confer over project
status together they'll look at a code
file in visual studio first we see Peter
Krebbs sand and I am including a desktop
sharing invitation to John Austin John
accepts and they discuss project status
with John typing his text in English and
Peter typing his text in german each of
them uses the translator pain in the
conversation window extension to see a
running translation while the
conversation went to itself shows the
original text then peter reports a
problem and opens visual studio on his
desktop john switches to the content
stage pain and link and they can both
look at the same document together share
comments and discuss a plan of action
john adds a comment and saves the file
you
the desktop sharing you saw in this
demonstration is available out of the
box with Lync 2013 I combine desktop
sharing with the translator sample
application which is available as a
download on the msdn sample site if you
want more information about the sample
application see part 2 of this video
where I'll do a short code walkthrough
in the sample
you